oh the world is this way and so you just
have to be the way that the world is
it's nonsense especially as a person of
Faith you're called to be set apart
you're called to be different than the
world what up guys welcome to the just
pearly things YouTube channel and
welcome to my reaction series if you
want women to come up to you and be the
ultimate high value male the ultimate
Alpha of women coming up to you left and
right get yourself a women shouldn't
vote t-shirt today they're a limited
edition they're flying off the shelves
they're the best T-shirt in the industry
so get yourself a t-shirt today the link
is in the description
um so today I want to talk about on
Twitter I often talk about how trade
cons and the red pill really talk past
each other and a lot of times it's so
funny because Trad cons can they'll
they'll call us the feminists and then
we also call them the feminists so I
want to decipher a conversation that's
happening
um I I don't even I forget this guy's
name but some the Trap like the tradcon
religion group
um on Twitter and he's talking about
fresh and fit so let's let's pull up the
reaction that he did and I think he's
reacted to me to I I don't know I don't
really watch The Red Pill Community is
in an inch spin on the downhill for
quite a few months with all sorts of
goofy stuff happening like Rallo to high
value man getting yourself snipped so
it's interesting the the tradcon
community is very like much into advice
and telling people to have a family the
the red pill Community we sort of stay
away from that because we believe and I
don't want to say we I don't want to put
words into anyone's mouth but in general
Rolo many people like Rolo believe that
every guy has to decide for himself and
the truth is there's an entire system
that is against men and the Trad cons
kind of want to pretend that it doesn't
exist and a lot of times they don't
really acknowledge just how risky
marriages today and they call us like
the Dooms and Dooms gloomers when it's
like on our end you know we've a lot of
us have interviewed and spoken to men
that have committed suicide or on the
track of suicide because of what a woman
has done to them and so um when Rolo
made this he said the fastest way to
become a high value guy he didn't say
the best he didn't say the most amazing
and then the the issue though is the
Trad cons come in and say well there's
no God in there if you don't have god
um then you're not really high value and
and then it's just you the conversation
always goes off the rails like it
literally always goes off the rail so
um okay this is what he says the
quickest way go and Andrew Tates
distancing themselves from Unity a lot
of this red pill how to get girl stuff
right I have a little bit of a gripe
with these guys
um I don't really understand why guys
will make off all this money off of the
red pill uh which really the red pill is
just it's the truth okay it's it's what
is true um and I don't really like that
they come in and then when the heat gets
too hot they kind of disavow it later
um I think it's a little you know a
little hypocritical to say well why
don't you you know you know why don't
like you guys should tell men to have a
family uh when again A lot of times you
know we've interviewed men that have had
a family and it's absolutely destroyed
them like I've interviewed guys that
absolutely would have been better off
single and this isn't Dooms and glooms
but this is just reality when you have a
system that actively discriminates
against men
um which you know the Trad cons really
deny is reality
um which it's so silly it's so it's like
the dumbest thing they're like
um they're like well it technically
doesn't say say in the laws that the men
can't get the kids and you're like okay
but look at the outcomes and the way
that the law is worded mostly men would
be affected and they just kind of deny
reality the same advice on the other
side but the conversation that I've been
inside of is some of the counter
interruptive prescription that are given
in the red pill Community I attempted to
have this conversation Ronaldo tomasi
when I debated him and it did not get
through unfortunately fresh and Fitz
channel has got well okay and the
prescriptions are in I'm gonna I'm gonna
go into the prescriptions later to the
temple and had this conversation and
we're finally brought the facts about
what some of their prescriptions and
their advice can do to men repeatedly
talked about everyone Dr David huberman
social psychologist this has been talked
about in his book The rationale talks
about spinning plates prioritizing women
that will give you and then the women
that won't so you're you're trying to
inflates and have multiple women that
you're talking to and they think that's
a pathway to build so I wanna I wanna
talk about who's in control of sex uh
women women are in control of Sex and
the
it's the women um and typically so like
basically let me let me just break down
the sexual Marketplace a lot of women
are sleeping with a small percentage of
men and you could gripe and whine about
oh well those those men shouldn't they
shouldn't you know sleep around but it's
like okay if you give cash to a homeless
guy are you mad like are you surprised
when he takes it and the truth of the
matter is women just keep taking off our
clothes I was walking around Vegas and
these chicks are like butt naked like
what happens first do men pursue sex or
do women take off their clothes I would
argue that women take off their clothes
first
um and so the issue we get is the
average man is not sleeping around so
it's like 80 percent of women are
involved in hookup culture 96 percent of
women are not virgins on their wedding
days only four percent of women are
virgins okay and if you take that four
percent what percent of them
um what percent of them are overweight
what percent of them are mentally
disabled like the majority of women
um I'm sorry like they we didn't pick
monogamy um and you kind of hear the
same old Trope where men will treat
women really well and no and women don't
appreciate it so they change and have
better results so the sexual Marketplace
Purity is on the women and it's so
interesting
um because really I would look at this
as a response to the women women don't
pick or want monogamy so the men Just Go
With It really like the men they just go
with it fresh and fit has talked about
men needing to rack up their body count
to 50. okay to be and the reason being
is because women typically want more
sexually experienced men and the way
that the red pill or Myra now I'm not
saying you should do this but what I'm
saying is every guy's got a pick for
himself but the way that Myron and them
they think okay Mo 96 of women aren't
virgins and most women want a more
sexually experienced guy so what what
other option do they have
um you know the other option is to stay
pure until marriage which sounds nice
but the odd odds are you're not going to
get a virgin chick there's more virgin
men than virgin women like that's just
the state of the marketplace so really I
put this on the chicks and the problem
is whenever like women do something
wrong or there's they always find a way
to blame it on the guy and this is just
like a common theme you're gonna see
from like tradcons whenever like women
are in control of sex men are in control
of relationships so whenever women
um you know if if if there's a bunch of
[__] like that's kind of on the women
more than the men especially because
again there's more virgin men than
virgin women they'll still find a way to
blame the men and so they could find out
everything they don't like all the women
they shouldn't deal with no and the
reason is to avoid predatory women
because what a lot of chicks will do and
and you see this with like Logan Paul
right what a lot of chicks will do and
this is just their solution I'm
personally not saying it's the best
solution or that's what you should
should do but the reason they they go
with that is because a lot of and
especially I'm sorry but the churches
have a rep mutation for this a lot
putting a lot of naive men in bad
situations men have everything to lose
in relationships right
um so it's really just a response until
they finally settle down like it seems
like the male version of radical
feminism no I would argue it's not the
male version because men don't have
power today men have no power you can be
nuanced that's the tunnel vision goal I
don't know if you've ever thought about
it when that becomes your primary is
you're training your brain you could
replace this with anything it's going to
imprint on your brain that behavior and
you engage in that behavior that's right
and over time what you're doing is
you're training your brain of what you
would think is happiness which that
becomes then the pattern that is
imprinted on your brain okay and this is
kind of the the Trope right well if you
sleep with too many women you won't be
happy if we have to talk about number
one all these institutions have been
infiltrated by feminists and like gender
studies profess so you don't even really
know but when I look in reality I just
don't see men really being affected as
much by sleeping around as women and the
truth of the matter is I've met a lot of
men that are absolutely in worse
positions because they had a family
instead of sleeping around now now look
at look at I'm not please do not say
pearl is saying to do that I'm saying
every man has to decide for himself he
has to look at the marketplace and
decide what he wants to do but the truth
of the matter is that men get absolutely
destroyed in divorce court they get
absolutely even if they don't make it
down the aisle a lot of men get
absolutely destroyed by child support by
alimony saying this isn't being a doom
and gloom person when I've had research
scientists tell me that there is a 15
chance that out of every 100 marriages
15 percent of women are malicious that
means trying to not let you see your
kids at all would you take a pill that
means also going after your assets that
you built would you take a pill if there
is a 15 chance that you would be
absolutely wrecked and most men don't
have the options to really get the women
that they want honestly and so what the
Trad cons will do is kind of Shame men
saying you know what this is too risky
I'm just gonna sleep around for a
lifetime or oh you know what I'm just
gonna go and like sleep around like I
got I'm not I don't want to be a part of
this when really the real problem is
these institutions that is the problem I
I can't shame men for not wanting to
take I I don't remember the exact number
but it's roughly a 15 percent of
marriage uh 15 of marriages uh and not
just fail but it's like ruthlessly like
like she is going after you with all the
false accusations that are happening
today like it's brutal and the Trad cons
like they want to live in this we're
really in a post-marriage world and I
don't I don't say this happily
um but there's a reason men used to get
married in three months and now it takes
them three to four years to put a ring
on it there's a reason and it's not
because their doom and gloomsday are men
men aren't walking away because they
just hate women it's because men are
really good at looking at the cost and
the benefit of the situation and you
know and the other thing is we have to
look at it from an evolutionary point of
view if a guy wants 10 kids most women
aren't willing to give that to them even
like more like quote unquote Trad con
women what I grew up in a family of 10.
where are the women that want to give a
man 10 kids I I haven't met any they
don't really exist and the Trad cons
will kind of go to this old trouble just
just go to church and find a good women
well the majority of the women in the
churches aren't virgins and until I
really am not going to take the tradcon
solution seriously until they start
telling men to demand virgins um from
Brides because that would really be the
real answer because you know um it goes
from an 80 chance of a happy marriage to
like a 50 chance with just one other
partner now maybe this is hypocritical I
know I know because that's what a lot of
emotionally driven men will come at me
and be like well what about you but like
I'm just looking at Solutions here you
know I don't think young women will
really switch behavior until they see
consequences for the older women out of
that right and to get out of that you
have to physically rewire you what he's
describing is a lot of what addiction is
what he's describing is the same thing
that Andrew huberman talks about and
I I hate but you know and and they'll
put all these studies and whatever and
this is why guys so many of these
studies are funded by liberals you don't
even understand that I just look in
reality and to be honest the guys I know
that have a lot of chicks uh don't
really seem that depressed or like broke
it like they kind of like make it seem
like they're just gonna you know go down
a rabbit hole and I'm not I'm I'm not
saying to do that but I just don't see
the same like emptiness dead inside that
I see from the women like the women it's
so obvious the men I mean do they do
they seem like depressed I don't know
and how there's an open feedback because
there are certain now the corn stuff I
see yeah that's but you know even even
corn I don't see the same effects as
women and you could you could argue that
you you also could argue that the corn
addiction is a response to women
sleeping with a smaller and smaller
percentage of men because you know there
are studies that say
um there are studies that say that that
it's a need for men
um and I know they'll be like Pearl
Pearl well do you want studies or not
want studies well I mean you got to look
at who funds these studies and that's
that's it's just the whole rabbit hole
but I think the number one the number
one way we can come to conclusions about
the world is by looking at it um but no
I I'm not for promiscuity I'm not for
sleeping around but what I'm not gonna
do is shame men for picking a path when
the the whole system is rigged it's
against them most of the women that are
lawyers are feminists most of these you
know judges are feminists everyone's
getting paid they make money off of
these men our release like dopamine but
then they're and the crazy thing oh this
is the crazy thing single mothers raise
worse children this isn't even disputed
they absolutely do and yet the courts
don't default raising the kids to the
father when all of these problems come
from single mother homes other things
like serotonin when you're interacting
with another human that also balance you
out right that's why it's different when
you are in Covenant marriage and you are
having intimacy with a spouse and all of
that being intact hormonally the right
the right chemicals being released
versus when you do it by yourself and
the reason I go back to men should
demand virgins for marriage isn't it I'm
gonna I'm gonna say I'm not even saying
a hundred percent that every man is
gonna demand virgin like come on we know
that's not it's to prove a point that
there is no humility from women and the
fact that we're coming in subpar and
then whining about the men it's like
where where like we have just lost
humility as a society or in this case if
you're just smashing through woman to
woman kicking them out of the of your
house as soon as you're done or you
leave as soon as you're done right it's
it's similar it's not exactly the same
but it's I think this is so great that
he pointed it out because there is a
neurochemical component meaning the way
your brain and the pathway is there are
all I need to do a whiteboard video on
I'm gonna do a wife so being affected
and you're creating a form of addiction
but see it's sort of like an egalitarian
model where he's kind of insinuating
it's like the same effects when you know
women tend to like men that sleep around
and I'll tell you this you know
um you know Destiny can say what he
wants on my show and be like oh women
don't like men that cheat but I look at
the body language which women smile when
they talk about their cheating stories
they're like smiling and laughing and
then when they talk about their exes
that were nice they look look depressed
like we're not blind and it's like okay
if we didn't like the men that were
cheaters why have we all dated one but
this is the problem it's like we're just
told men and women are the same and we
have the same that by the time the man
are ready to be the best what I think
I'll die on this hill there's nothing
satisfying yeah because your wife didn't
destroy you I'm really glad you came out
on the good side but let's like look at
these odds and this isn't this isn't to
be a doom and gloomsday this isn't my
intention I just can't look at the world
and not see what it is half of marriage
is ending divorce and out of the people
that stay married women have a horrible
reputation
um most women don't believe in
submission most women were not virgins
on their wedding days most women don't
have traditional skills and there's a
reason we have phrases in society like
happy wife happy life it's cheaper to
keeper there's a reason why we have
phrases like she wears the pants because
men don't have any leverage and women
know that they're paid to leave and the
problem is with female Natures we're
very easily influenced and even a good
women
um can be influenced by the wrong crowd
that's why we have phrases like she was
brainwashed that's why like think about
even the Trad it's so funny because
tradcons will admit they'll say women
were brainwashed by this and not think
that it's possible that a woman could be
brainwashed to leave her husband are you
crazy like we all can't like that's our
problem that's why like that's why
society's gone literally downhill since
women have gotten power most
statistically speaking and most women
majority will at some point so if you
know that that is going to happen why
would you then give advice
counter-intuitive to create structure
specifically a nuclear family the
majority of men didn't reproduce
historically and they're not predicting
that the next generation of women it's I
mean I guess you could say most 55
percent will have kids that's still a
very very big minority that doesn't I
mean I think 20 25 of women over 40
don't have kids right now
um we are not going to see families the
same way we used to oh we already don't
go into any go into any um place that
used to be primarily families like you
go into movie theater
um uh like what do you call it like
roller rink any of that stuff it's like
mostly single people um and when you do
see families it's usually maybe two kids
maybe like I grew up with um it's kind
of a weird story I had uh 10 adopted
total but when I was growing up there
was six of us and I was the second to
six and
um I just don't see it like going out
into the world I don't I don't see a lot
of people with that many kids and when
you think about it two kids really is
feminism because before the feminist
movement which really started uh
mid-1800s but really got picked up steam
in the early 1900s um uh women had like
seven kids each two kids as a result of
feminism Family Planning woman husband
wife mother father in the house why
would you give any advice that gives you
people meaning that if you're just
racking up your body count you're more
likely to like yeah but if you get
married you're more likely to get
financially ruined have your kids turned
against you and I I don't say this to be
a doom and glooms person but um a lot of
these guys haven't done the research
into this stuff and it just kind of
shows because they're very like ignorant
um you know yeah they might like it's
kind of like every guy sort of just has
to pick his poison if I'm being honest
he has to pick what risk he wants to
take he can have the risk of addiction
he can have the risk of STD like that
he's right that is one risk
um but the other risk is you know I've
seen men I've seen women turn men's kids
against them and make them I mean we see
what propaganda does to women right it's
the same thing on children um you have
women in the kids ears for 20 years
talking about things they don't like
about their dad
um you have kids publicly disrespecting
their father
um and you know I interviewed a divorce
attorney about this and he really talked
about how when a man has kids they're
not his his own and guys I I don't say
this like I'm happy about it and it's so
funny because I could make so much more
money just telling people what they want
to hear the solution is fam like that's
what the Chad cons do they talk about it
the solution is family but the solution
is changing the laws to lower the risk
for men that's the real solution because
you know
um and really women bringing more value
with women bringing virginity back to
the table and until you get until
tradcons get on women as much for not
being virgins I just don't take this
stuff seriously because they're not
they're not really going to the the real
root of the problem I mean virgin women
have an 80 chance of a happy marriage if
you go to a couple people it goes down
to like 20 right 20 30 chance um and we
can just look at this anecdotal even
without the studies we can look at what
has happened since women have been not
virgins on their wedding day it's been
more crazy right um and then you see all
these criminals coming from single
mother homes all these School shooters
coming from single mother homes all of
these mentally ill people coming from
single mother homes women raise chaotic
kids it just doesn't work my issue is
that the the Trad cons shame men for not
wanting to take that risk it's really
one risk or another get yourself a baby
mama having a child out of wedlock
arguably one of the worst economics he's
he's correct he he is correct and but he
also did you you know what's so funny he
also shamed them in the beginning for
getting a vasectomy it's like whenever a
guy makes a decision that puts him in
the position of power he shamed for it
right in terms of what that does in
order for them to to get into that state
and not still be in this cycle of
needing to get that get over years and
years because when you think about it if
women die tend to want men until their
late 20s early 30s right that's kind of
when you hear from guys that's when it's
sort of the game kind of switches what
is a guy supposed to do until then I
mean that takes time and it's hard that
results in my opinion marriages that's
right divorces yes poems that's right
and it creates a whole another cycle of
chasing and it's so funny because I'll
hear these tropes and it's it's so
interesting guys maybe 10 20 of men can
do this um I think top one percent of
sexual selectivity for men is like 50
bodies so what they're groaning on and
on about is what maybe 10 of men can do
yet 96 of women chose non-virginity and
a hundred percent of women have the
option to do that think about that think
about that and so what I'll hear often
is that well you know women we have to
say it nicely oh no oh no that doesn't
help us and I know women respond really
well to social shame and you should
absolutely prioritize chasing your
purpose prioritize purpose over pleasure
you're gonna have to to learn to delay
gratification in all aspects and if that
becomes your North Star and those of us
who are in Christ G that our purpose
owes us to know God and make him known
that is the North Star no God to make
him know well then we have to prioritize
pleasure and make that make sure that
pleasure is submitted to us chasing our
purpose to us pursuing the very things
that God has for I can argue as well the
woman one woman right multiple times
you're pair bonding and you're building
intimate with the woman cuddling there's
nothing else well you could argue that
but most people who are in any type of
some sort of intimacy outside of just
physical intimacy they're hanging out
they're doing stuff they're raising a
family right there yeah but then this
kind of just goes back to picking and
choosing sin I see this a lot build
yourself up as a result I mean that
choice not knowing so I ask you a
question right these guys are just full
of battles I actually disagree I don't
care but I don't really care how the
illustration makes you feel I don't
really care go to salesman talked about
the car let's drive it I'm just saying
for most men it's a goal but not the end
and all bill it's a part of the
understanding how the party repertoire
so when you meet the woman good as a
person all right full package I'm not
saying that that's the end Global and
for you to be able to come to that you
know rational rationally sound and
logically sound conclusion that this
girl is the right one yeah that's what
they don't talk about predatory women
and a lot of predatory women go to the
church there's a reason
churches
women do this too women do the same
thing develop reputations and then blame
everyone else for the reputation there's
a reason that church girls have a
certain reputation of not being better
than the women outside at the church
like it there's a reason for it
um and I'm sorry but you see this in
churches all the time where um naive men
pick women that really have had a crazy
crazy past most women are not worthy of
a long-term relationship so guys need to
be able to vet women correctly otherwise
they're the ones that take all the risks
so I get what you're saying where you're
saying like hey this might be
destructive respect men the same way it
affects women pair bonding and having
high Partners
it's just not true like it's just not
true it's just not true this notion that
men can go and rack up their body but if
a woman racks up her body no he said
it's he said it's not the same let me go
back I'll double check women correctly
otherwise they're the ones that take all
the risks so I get what you're saying
yeah so Myron's basically saying look it
we have all this downside women have all
this upside for doing the wrong thing we
have all this downside for doing the
right thing so you know I gotta I gotta
vet these chicks and this is the thing
there's so much risk for guys that I I
understand why the conclusion is like
I'm not gonna shame a guy if he wants to
and look at I I'm not saying he should
if that's the path that he chooses where
he says you know what I got to deal with
a lot of chicks to figure out which ones
are good and which ones are bad women
absolutely are manipulative they can run
game they absolutely can hey this might
be destructive effect men the same way
it affects women no so he says the same
way the same way okay having high
Partners
it's not true like it's just not true
it's just not true this notion this is
delicious you hear this King like I
don't understand like I don't understand
why they live in like delusion you know
what I mean I'm not saying like guys
should sleep around but like I I they go
back to the egalitarian principle where
they're acting like men and women are
the same sleeping around isn't the same
for men and for women I'm not saying
either is good but it's just not the
same but these guys like a preacher or
something right most preachers are
already they are done most of them Panda
to women because basically it's not even
their fault it's what has been taught to
them and what has been handed out to
them like you said yeah like I always
say the church has been infiltrated and
the reality is I haven't been to a
church in past 10 years that has
actually addressed female sin like you
like you said yeah most of the time is
always the men yeah we get to the men
are the leaders but you cannot lead a
society where the followers don't want
to follow you know you know what's so
funny so this guy I forgot what he was
like he was tweeting at me and so like
because this is they'll always like
shame everybody for their reputation
right so they'll say well what churches
do you go to when it's like you know
I've talked to hundreds of people like
do you know how many Christian women
we've had on this show so we have
Christian women from all these different
churches spouting on out the same
nonsense and they'll be like oh it's
just well it's just the women that you
pick on the show we're like uh no
they're very random like we don't know
who's coming on and I'm like well I've
played on T like it's like you know
we're not blind and
um it's so funny because they'll blame
like everyone else like the men for not
wanting to go instead of asking like
what the real problem is really what you
actually said is actually very true they
are trying to make it seem as if the
real problem is with the men when in
reality it's only a small percentage of
men that can even anticipate in the
sexual Marketplace at all every other
man is locked out so like most men are
locked out from the sexual Marketplace
but most women are participating even
the ones that you would think that uh
she probably wouldn't get any takers she
she probably has a high body count well
even but that's that that's why my point
is I'm like even at two right which like
I mean according to the guys they're
like a girl that has two bodies is
amazing right for today or at three it's
like the the rate of Happiness still
draw I think it drops below 50 at three
partners and so it's like with these
numbers like most men aren't root like
ruining virgin women it's women that are
already ruined if I'm being honest do
you know where where the church lost it
the church started going leaning towards
this whole Prosperity Gospel because
what that is is the whole Prosperity
Gospel is basically rooted in capitalism
right it's written is all about money
they are basically worshiping money
that's what they're doing keep money
flowing you have to make sure that the
people that are coming to church keep
coming to church obviously the men have
all checked out so it's the women right
so what do you do to keep the women
there you make sure you don't see things
that will keep them away from church
okay you know what's oh I forgot this is
what was funny so he he um he said
something to me about he like is this
what they'll do but they'll be like well
I'll take you to my church my church I
know I know I know I know the same
reaction oh my God okay what church do
you go to he won't tell me if your
church is so special and this is the
thing like I'm a Catholic right but I'll
even admit feminism's in the Catholic
church I'm not gonna go around saying oh
no oh no it's not my church's special oh
no and I know great women that are
Catholic I know women that waited till
they were married like I know good women
but the choice the truth of the matter
is they were rare and the truth of the
matter is
um they did have pretty high standards
right and the truth of the matter is
there's still a lot of woke [__] in
church things some of the kinds of
clothes that women were to even some of
these Protestant churches oh yeah and
this is the thing that's why I said like
what comes first do women take their
clothes off or do men pursue sex and I
would argue that women take their
clothes off first because you see it you
see women taking off their clothes at
work you see it on the streets and then
they're like oh well not all women are
like that like I can already hear like
the gut reactions because it's just we
just have this gut like reaction to
defend women and put it on the men now
and it goes back to it I think it's
because like men know that we're just so
easily influenced and brain well like
they kind of know it in their gut that
we just kind of do this silly stuff but
if that's true then the policies need to
reflect that you know what I mean like
we're either equal right and we want to
be equal or we're not equal and we have
to give up some of the freedoms but
right now they want both and yeah so and
that men can go and rack up their body
count but if a woman racks up her body
count it's over for her is like
funny okay because and I'm sure you know
part of this because I'm sure like maybe
the marriage rate goes down the more
that the guys sleep around but yeah like
the more that the guys that sleep around
know everybody's a [__] and they're
like why would I why would I do this and
they see like the guys that sleep around
see the worst parts of female nature
because they've slept with a lot of your
wives unfortunately you know what I mean
like they're the guys that like they're
like yeah all these chicks made it down
the aisle and I I got that for like you
know and like this is what I hear from
guys they're like the more they sleep
around the more like the illusion of
women wears off so yeah I'd imagine they
probably don't think we're as special or
important you know they're just like oh
woman that suggests that in this regard
what do you mean some research like
he's downplaying and I'm like some
research really watch watch like two of
my shows with only fans models versus
the men of the equivalent oh it's not
the same oh it's way worse a woman that
slept with 50 men is done not an AC
there's no coming back she's ruined for
life a man that slept with 50 women can
probably still get a wife like I just
this is just reality generally speaking
both men and women if you have a lot of
Partners but it's so funny because he
they'll talk about the consequences for
um this but they never talk about the
consequences of getting married you're
gonna have to deal with the consequence
okay 15 chance of getting obliterated
obliterated uh like I don't I don't I
don't say this in a happy way struggle
to pair bond in the partners you have
the harder it will be for the harder it
will be for you to maintain a
relationship and the more likely you are
to get the monogamous Christian Mary
virgins and honestly when I talk about
the virgins really it's just to kind of
show the hypocrisy you know what I mean
because I've just never I have heard so
many Christian tropes about the men you
should avoid avoid men that are going to
use you avoid this but I have never
heard a preacher say Mary only virgin
women you don't have to accept her past
don't accept that don't fall for it only
like demand have you ever I've never
heard that have you I've only heard
about Redemption when and that sounds
nice right but but the truth of the
matter and there is there's a whole hell
of a lot of single women in church and
for a lot of us about half there there's
not going to be a happy ending and the
more shows I do the more people I talk
to the more I'm I'm convinced that we're
in a post-marriage society until women
start adding more value or we lower the
risk Men Are Gonna Keep sleeping around
and just yeah that that's I'm the men
that can't sorry sorry women are going
to keep sleeping around a small
percentage of men and that it's just
going to be a post-marriage world so
this this idea that like I don't know
how many people you guys know men how
many men you guys know that have high
body counts meaning like I know a couple
guys that are like 50s 60s hundreds all
these guys all these guys struggle to
maintain healthy relations struggling in
their own personal I know quite a few
guys that are struggling because they
got married you know like we could play
this game which is why I say every guy's
got a pick for himself right men are
just very good at weighing the the costs
and the benefits every guy I'll just
look this is the cost this is the
benefit and they weigh it out and they
decide it's really on on the men
um I I think like I think it's wrong to
kind of tell us to shame a guy either
way yeah pick your poison racked up his
body count function and Thrive are are
really struggling struggling personally
struggling and it's hard you're true
you're right about the parabon rich man
look at science tells us about global
warming science it's not like science
told us all to get vaccinate like it's
like we can't even we can't trust
anything anymore I just gotta look at
reality I just gotta look at the world
and look at what I see and I I just will
not be convinced that men that sleep
around have the same issues that women
that sleep around do it's just not true
just hook up culture whatever I'm sure
you guys do really well dude King do
Myron and fresh seem like traumatized do
they seem like just I mean I guess I
guess they did lose their Channel
recently that is a bad example do you
think you think it was because of the
women maybe reporting them
I understand that okay promiscuity can
affect so so let me so he conceded
curious it sounds like you guys are
saying hey this is the way the world is
and your view is more like oh the world
is this way and so you just have to be
the way that the world is is nonsense
especially as a person in faith you're
called to be set apart you're called to
be different than the world yeah but
that's it's like like one not everyone
has faith and again the churches are not
addressing why people are losing faith
in religion why people are leaving the
church
um and you know sometimes spinning
plates for some guys is just going on
dates with a bunch of chicks and until
they find a girl they let like it's
different for every guy but the truth of
the matter the truth of the matter is
right now the government financially
like I would even go as far to say that
the government like abuses men in the
system it's so sad you know I've
interviewed men that are crying because
like that are on the verge of tears
because they haven't seen their kids in
a year that live a mile from them and
you just say well you you can't adapt
like you can't let the world change you
well I mean I think men are allowed to
avoid risks and it's pretty risky to get
married nowadays even without the
government it's pretty risky to have
kids this is an article that has been
around for young men driving the
declinance so this is interesting
they'll use this graph men are having
and that's true so this this chart shows
that eight almost thirty percent almost
the Third third of men I would also like
to point out that marriage rates have
also declined but at the same time
there's also women 18 of women who
almost went out of uh four women have
also not had can we google the percent
of women that are obese
like extreme obesity what percent of
women I bet you this is all the fatties
fat chicks but and we all know if if
it's saying a third of men are sexless
it's higher we all know if 20 percent of
women say they're virgins it's lower
like we know this is just the general
who is it easier have casual sex it's
easier for women right in terms of like
those numbers aren't that crazy it's
like oh my gosh one out of last year
okay one out of four women have it this
96 percent of women aren't virgins on
their wedding days that's what I'll give
you and and plus the other problem is
women sleep up so you'll see fives and
sixes sleeping seven sleeping with the
tens and so sometimes women will be
sexless because they're like shooting
too high well but not really what
percent of women but but see even I can
dismantle his whole argument the reality
is it doesn't matter how promiscuous men
wants to be if women are opening their
legs to men then men will be able to
have sex it's as simple as that like all
these going after men the men that can
have sex with so many women as if it's
the man's fault they are not forcing
these women to have sex with them well
and most of them aren't like virgin
women like most of the women they're
sleeping with have done this [__] before
yeah yeah if he wants to come at it from
a religious angle then he should also
add logic to his um to his argument men
can't have sex with women that don't
want to have sex with them a small
minority of men are having sex with all
the women then you should actually first
address those women to start closing
their legs then you can address the men
to fix up I'm just curious what percent
of women 48 of women have very high
waist measurements four percent of women
are morbidly obese
um I mean I know 70 of us so it's like
yeah so that we gotta we gotta get rid
of the the fat skyrockets that that
deviation really comes into effect I
think the internet plays a big role in
this there's
you notice it went up for both you
notice that it's the highest it's ever
been for both genders be sad about this
many women have to have obviously
there's a point to be made about maybe
well and like come on how many chicks
have we had come on the show that say
they're virgin when they're clearly not
like I I think I'm I mean we one we
don't have many women that claim
virginity anyway but it's like out of
like what the five I can think of that
said they were three I think there's
maybe one in a year and a half of shows
I believe the other was like half naked
you know so it's like mostly are still
having that you Tim you're not looking
at the issue here is that the most
promiscuous people are having the most
promiscuous with other promiscuous
people that's what's happening most
folks aren't are out here running around
that uh you know 100 bodies that's that
says that well he said most people are
not running around with 10 bodies he
should correct that most men are not
right now with 10 bodies I would argue
that most women have at least 10 bodies
yeah I mean and this is the thing like
okay if we're getting into a society
where men are saying under 10 is okay
what does that say about the body count
of women well you see you know enough
anything about people like because what
I'll say about someone like him is
obviously he's Christian he probably got
married very early and like he's
probably faithful to his wife no idea
what the sexual Marketplace is like so
he can make all this judgment from his
high pedestal Christian
um Tower but he actually doesn't know
what now and she demand us yeah all
these women can tell you the kind of
women that are out there those are the
kind of men I know that's what not him
that's what I say the men that are
sleeping with a lot of women I'm sorry
they know the most because like like a
guy that slept with 300 women is Gonna
Know way more about women than a dude
who married one so it's you know a
portion of men slowly removed women are
maintaining them that's an interesting
social thing and that plays a huge role
be glad you brought this up because that
plays a huge role as to what women think
they deserve average girl can hang out
with that plays a huge role of what they
think they deserve what they make the
mistake of they think just because I can
attract this but that plays a huge role
because girls think they deserve best if
you what do you want she's going to
describe to an exceptional man and even
more so thanks for feminism have their
own cars they have their own ability to
provision for so since they're able to
get all these things that they no longer
need a dutiful responsible leadership
Driven Man because they're like yo I
just want the hot guy now that's true
women are selecting for looks before
money now I think what he's saying here
is true true in his world true in the
world of and it's true in the church too
look I'm sorry I'm sorry you guys
delusional like yeah it's really
delusional and I'm sorry to say about
bro you you actually don't know anything
about women you you married one woman
and you think you're like the the what's
it called the alpha on women's studies
breath
well now you know what's so funny like I
I went I was in this Christian it was
like a non-denominational church for a
couple years and um yeah it's like all
single women it's like there's so many
single women in the church so like
they're they're saying oh like women
aren't like that where the women don't
lower their standards in church we'd all
be married I'd like to find out what's
churchy he won't tell you like if you
the thing is if I could find out the
church and I could get a video of maybe
one of his service I want to see the
kind of women that come to his church
and I can tell you that just by looking
at that video I can probably point out
all the kind of all the women in there
that I'll be promiscuous just by looking
at the video and again like my point is
if women in the church were really
better they would have a reputation for
being better then like people would say
okay go go to that church like you can
find a wife they run to where the women
are there's a reason there's like ladies
and nights and all this stuff if the
women in the church were that good men
would be running to the church that's
[__] because yeah let's look at it
like this if for instance his church was
so special and you could find wipes
obviously the people that have married
would have good reviews and then more
men will go and get wives from there and
have even more reviews and yeah I know
it it will be a go-to place
um if people are having successful
marriages come out of his church that is
all the evidence you need yeah but okay
so why why aren't people running to his
church to get married well and the other
the other issue I've even heard him say
that like women um it's okay to get
married after the age of like 25 to 35
and I know the audience is gonna be like
Pearl hypocrite hypocrite whatever okay
yeah I get it but like it's like okay if
you do not push young marriage you're
encouraging promiscuity because what who
is gonna wait till 25 26 27 20. you know
what I mean and so it's like the the 22
year olds 100 years ago got married and
stayed married fine but it's it's it's
the culture and the fact that we let
women get away with everything and men
don't demand virgins for marriage if if
he doesn't preach for women to get
married young obviously he's he's
indirectly in support of promiscuits
yeah that's [__] yeah and then they're
like well why don't you just have
self-control yeah okay tell a bunch of
hormonal teenagers like like people
could wait like and I actually think men
if men knew okay hey at 21 or 22 you
wait till you're 22 you get a virgin
bride who's going to give you five
children if you want them that you get
to provide for for a lifetime she can't
leave the men wouldn't like I mean
there's always going to be guys that
sleep around but a lot of guys would
take that deal like 21 like people could
wait till they're 21 20 but when you
start you start pushing like now the
average age of marriage is 31 good luck
you know what's funny too what they'll
do they'll always show me that like
there's a higher divorce rate when women
are like 18 and they get married but I
would argue that's the culture because
women we just love to feel like we're
part of the group we hate missing out
when all of our friends are like out
partying and doing all this fun stuff we
feel like we missed out and that's why
like I I see the women get divorced at
like you know they get married at 18
because they feel like they cashed out
too soon and now they missed out on a
yacht with Drake these people okay but
even now I'm from the Midwest shut up
like like
I know people from Kansas that talk
about this the internet's everywhere and
even like average checks can still like
it doesn't have to be like I use Drake
just because Drake has like wall of like
bras that women throw at him but it
doesn't have to be Drake it could be the
best guy in the city nearest to her so
like I'm from you know the Chicago
suburbs my mom was from a small town in
Wisconsin so maybe it's white water
that's a big town in Wisconsin or or
Green Bay you know what I mean like the
best guys in those cities it doesn't
have to be a national celebrity but the
truth of the matter is the peasant would
always leave for the king I'm sorry
women like that's just how women are you
don't have to hate like you don't have
to hate women for it and that's the
problem with the red pill is some of the
facts that aren't so nice about women
the conclusion from tradkins is that you
have to hate women for it no you just
have to protect women from ourselves and
that's why there's always been
institutions in place in history to
protect us from ourselves because left
to our own devices we just don't choose
that well sorry you know and that's why
we have phrases like Daddy Issues you
know there's a reason we have these
these phrases in society because without
male guidance we just don't we it goes
poorly
um and women just have a tendency to
leave for the next best guy if she
thinks she can really attain him um you
know men are a lot more content sorry
ladies I'm telling on us you know and
then they're going to be like oh Pearl
it's just you sorry let me just make
sure I want to just check something and
just make sure that this point I want to
make oh geez okay so from here right
yeah yeah
for four minutes all the way to 13 look
at his body language his legs are
crossed bro how are you not letting that
[__] breathe like this is not nice this
is this is weird oh I guess I noticed
the cross legs too he's sitting like
this for over 10 minutes straight well
it's usually like that and you kind of
start to to see these archetypes like um
yeah the like feminine guys in the
church and they tend to have more like
feminine body language and um in the
church I see it usually it's either
single moms but no oh no sorry not
single moms in the church it's a lot of
divorced women or domineering women so a
lot of like the mutual submission like
basically submit to my husband when I
feel like it wouldn't get wisdom from
your wife like I couldn't even believe
that that is I will never let this go
that some chick was like talking about
me because I said men shouldn't get
wisdom from their wives look at look at
the wisdom we bring we bring nonsense
and the thing is I'd even just point
that out to shame him or anything it's
just the reality is yeah there is
something about body language or
something about commanding your audience
like young guys are not going to listen
to this guy and take any advice from him
not even because of what he's saying
there's just something when a masculine
man is speaking to men or other boys or
young but there is yeah there is a way
it communicates and it comes across well
if the guy is holding his proper frame
well and and the issue a lot of times
with guys that don't hold frame what
you'll see is you'll you'll they'll
shame the guys that do so they'll shame
like the Tates the trumps and they'll
say oh well young boys shouldn't be
listening to him and like he's not like
moral and like it starts to become like
a sin comparison well they cheated they
did this so they're not like moral
enough to listen to and the truth of the
matter is if you had the frame that men
wanted to listen to they'd listen to you
but they don't responsible leadership
Driven Man because they're like yo I
just want the hot guy now I can
provision for myself I think what he's
through in his world it's true and now
it's not women mate select for looks
first that's like not you did the world
competent priest provider and protector
wife down that shares the same values as
you who's a virgin woman bird say virgin
say virgin attractive or you're
attracted to Virgin you see like
whenever there's a standard that meant
like that that should be a reasonable
standard I know Pearl's a hypocrite but
it's like it's like shouldn't that that
should be the reasonable uh whatever
Wilt Chamberlain was a professional
basket with a thousand and Will
Chamberlain said I know what it's like
to have to put a thousand women but I
much prefer now with one woman a
thousand yeah that's probably because he
doesn't want his wife to know he's
cheating
okay I'm gonna go
um yeah so I just really wanted to point
out a lot of hypocrisy from the Trad
cons I just I I it's hard because I
really I I started as a Trad con when I
first got into red pill and red pill is
just the truth it's truth about the
world and honestly Myron made points in
this Myron is the only one in that room
that really has a good grasp on The
Dating Market he's interviewed hundreds
of women and I'll tell you guys they've
had women on from all over it's not just
I used to think that too until I was in
their shoes and I was like oh god oh no
but you know what's so funny I already
can hear the reaction channels coming to
me they'll be like religious enough to
talk doesn't understand and then it just
becomes another the moral place but you
know let me know what you guys think in
the comments and like the video on your
way out uh let's get this video to 2 000
likes get yourself a women shouldn't
vote t-shirt today and I'll talk to you
next time